donc grâce au grand james grime et à
tous les principaux youtubeurs mathématiques comme
freeboo et braun
matt parker et numberphile, il y a
actuellement un grand youtuber mathématique qui sort
où chacun de nous révèle son
nombre méga 5
et bien pour être honnête
je n'ai pas vraiment  un numéro méga 5, je
ne suis pas ce genre de personne,
je veux dire tous les numéros de mes amis,
je suppose, mais comme je suis un navire et que je
veux participer, j'ai posé une question légèrement
différente, à
savoir si je devais  signer ma
pierre tombale
avec un numéro quel serait ce
numéro pour
quel numéro voudrais-je qu'on se
souvienne de moi
et bien aujourd'hui au moins ce serait ce
numéro ici
alors qu'est-ce que c'est pourquoi je me soucierais même
de ce
numéro eh bien vous savez comment les mathématiciens
sont  en fait très
narcissique et ils voulaient juste
prouver ce
théorème qu'ils resteront éternellement dans les mémoires
car je suis un mathématicien et j'ai
fait des choses
qui ne me dérangeraient pas d'être éternellement
rappelées
en fait à partir d'aujourd'hui à l  est la seule
chose pour laquelle je voudrais le
plus qu'on se souvienne de
moi est probablement mon tout premier livre sur la
théorie des probabilités et ses
applications étonnantes à
une gamme extrêmement variée de domaines, donc
je suppose que
j'aimerais qu'on se souvienne de ce
livre
bien sûr mon nom est  déjà sur le
livre mais mon nom est l'un des noms les plus
courants
au monde je veux dire les mueren huang
avez-vous déjà essayé de le chercher sur google il y a des
milliards d'entre nous
je veux dire maman et papa sérieusement vouliez-vous
que ma vie soit
différemment privée alors  peut-être devrais-je
signer mon livre
avec quelque chose qui m'identifie vraiment
et non avec un autre
mauvais linguine bien la cryptographie a un
truc
pour ça ça s'appelle la
signature électronique maintenant je n'entrerai pas dans tous les
détails de la façon dont cela fonctionne réellement d'
autres vidéos ont mais brièvement je  j'ai
une paire de soi-disant clés privées publiques
ma clé privée est bien privée et moi seul le
sais
ou plutôt seul mon ordinateur le sait je
veux dire
c'est un assez grand nombre mais ma
clé publique est publique
en fait, vous pouvez le vérifier, c'est
juste ici et donc en
utilisant un protocole cryptographique appelé
rsa avec d'autres techniques, j'ai demandé à
mon ordinateur de mélanger le pdf de mon livre
avec ma clé privée pour laisser une signature
que moi seul
peux générer ou  plutôt que seul un
ordinateur avec ma clé privée
peut générer maintenant je dois dire que cela
n'empêche pas
certains utilisateurs malveillants de prétendre que
ce sont eux qui ont réellement écrit le
livre
en fournissant leur propre signature en
mélangeant le pdf avec leurs propres clés privées
si je voulais vraiment tamponner ce pdf comme
étant le produit
de mon travail, ce serait en fait une bonne
idée de télécharger également
ma signature sur plusieurs
chaînes de blocs fiables à grande échelle, par exemple,
mais je suppose que la vidéo youtube est
la meilleure chose à faire,
mais ce que mon  la signature permet est
qu'en combinant ma signature avec la clé publique,
n'importe qui peut maintenant vérifier que j'ai vérifié
cette version
du livre s'il voit une version du
livre et s'il
veut vérifier qu'il est  la version que
j'ai écrit en
utilisant ma signature et ma clé publique
ils
peuvent autrement dit ma signature permet d'
authentifier
la bonne version du livre c'est
pourquoi ce numéro qui pour des
raisons cryptographiques n'aurait pas pu être produit
si ce n'était pas pour mon livre  et ma clé privée
est vraiment une sorte de signature de ma
plus grande réussite
c'est pourquoi cette signature est le grand
nombre
que cette vidéo et peut-être ma pierre tom
même si j'ai encore des doutes
devrais-je vraiment faire ça de toute façon
c'est ce que cette vidéo est tout  sur